KASE.
AND ZUCKER WITH A SHOT.
SIX  BY
MATTHEWS, GOOD PASS.
WHAT A CHANCE FOR IT UP
ASTON REESE
KNOCKED IT DOWN.NSTEAD GUENTZE
OUTSIDE AND YOU CAN SEE SANDIN
BACKHAND BY CAMPBELL.
SHORTLY AFTERND NICE LITTLE
CONFIDENCE.
GOOD PASS THROUGH THE MIDDLE
FIRST PERIOD.
THE
LINE.
LOOK BY RICHIE.
BY LETANG.HE NE GETTING TO THIE
OFF THE CHECK.
AND HE MAKES THE NICE PASS IN
FRONT.
LOOK AT JARRY.
HAD IT BOUNCED ON HOLL, AND
JEFF CARTER GETS A TAP-IN GOAL.
AS HE'S ABLE TO FIND THAT ONE .
THAT WAS BRIAN ROSS.
OUR VIDEO COACH FOR SO MANY
YEARS.
MCGINN.
GETTING PAST SANDIN IN  COUPLE
GOALS.
AND HERE'S ANOTHER
>> Craig: YOU HAVE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF YOUR OPPORTUNITIES
MITCH
POWER PLAY GETS A CHANC.
ONE IN.
CROSBY WITH A
QUICK RELEASE.
A BIT OF A FLOP AND TUCK GOES
OFF OF JARRY AND OFF THE BAR
SAVE TO KEEP THINGS.
CASPERY KAPANEN DIGGING IN.
>> Craig: YOU MENTIONED
KAPANEN WITH A COUPLE OF
ASSISTS LAST TIME THESEL GREAT.
SEVEN GOALS IN 35 LAST YEAR.
H DOWN
LOW.
ANOTHER E BODY TO PROTECT THE
PUCK WELL.
WATCH
HERE.NAL GAME
GOOD MOVE FROM THE FAR SIDE.
ENGVALL WHO ON THAT LINE
TRYING TO DECK IN FRONT.
CARTER TO THE G TO IT.
THAT'S A GOOD HARD WORK SHIFT.
KEEPS THE PLAY ALIVE.
FOR BUNT.
WHERING WHERING THIS LINE ONCE
AGAIN GETSCOMEBACK HERE.
TO THE TURN AROUND AND
JARRY DOWN IN THE
MARNER.
TAVARES DROPS IT BACK AND
IN FRONT!
>> Craig: DESPERATION FOR THE
LEAFS FIVE ON THREE.
TWO OF THOSE I
THREE.
AND NOWS
PIECE OF IT.